-President Trump's former
secretary of defense said,
in a book and interview,
that Trump wanted
to shoot protesters
and called his own
senior officials,
including
Vice President Mike Pence,
effing losers.
Meanwhile,
the committee investigating
the January 6th insurrection
is considering whether
to hold Rudy Giuliani
in contempt
for pulling out
of a scheduled interview.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
So, it seems there are two kinds
of former Trump associates
who emerge every day.
The first is someone like former
Defense Secretary Mark Esper,
who was on "60 Minutes"
last night
and who wants you to think
he stayed
in the Trump administration
as a check
on Trump's worst instincts.
But, now that he has
a book to promote,
he's willing to tell you
exactly how bad it was.
The other kind are people
like Rudy Giuliani.
They don't have books to promote
because they are open books,
telling you everything
about themselves
and every waking moment.
[ Laughter ]
Rudy is like
a human pop-up book,
[ Laughter ]
the kind you return
to the store
because it gave
your kid nightmares.
[ Laughter ]
Should be noted, if Rudy was
a kid's book character,
he would be
a reverse Cinderella.
He used to be known
as America's Mayor
and, now,
you wouldn't be surprised
to see him trying to drive
a giant pumpkin.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Giuliani ]
It won't start.
I think the seeds are
in the engine.
[ Laughter ]
I feel comfortable saying
Rudy is the weirdest man
in the history of politics.
Last week,
he posted a video of himself
[ Laughter ]
on the golf course,
swinging a club back and forth,
wearing what were either pants
he stole from Gap Kids
or shorts he stole
from Big & Tall.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Giuliani ]
The great thing about these
pants is they're perfect
for zero occasions.
[ Laughter ]
It just seems like there are no
ways those pants aren't medical.
The saleslady were like,
"They're very stylish
and they release Lipitor
right into your bloodstream."
[ Laughter ]
Then there's the fact he just
keeps swinging the club
back and forth.
[ Laughter ]
He looks like a great-,
great-, great-,
great-,
great-grandfather clock.
[ Laughter ]
Anyway, the point is
he's a weird dude
and, yet, he does not seem,
in any way, aware
of his weirdness or the
perception of him as a weirdo.
For example, Rudy pulled out
of a scheduled interview
with the committee investigating
the January 6th insurrection
and he did it
for a typically weird reason.
-Former Trump attorney
Rudy Giuliani
has backed out
of an appearance
before the
January 6th Committee.
He was supposed to take part
in an interview today,
but a spokesman
for the panel said
Giuliani is now refusing
to participate,
unless he is permitted
to record the interview.
[ Laughter ]
-Why does he want to record
the interview?
Is he worried they're going to
cut it together
to make it sound bad?
That's what his brain
already does to his mouth.
[ Laughter ]
What do guys like Rudy always
have Some weird angle,
like thinking they're
a genius chess master
calling their bluff
by asking to record the meeting,
but anytime Rudy
has ever been recorded,
it's always been bad for him.
He was recorded calling
a senator
on the day of the insurrection,
to get him
to overturn the results.
He was recorded butt-dialing
a reporter
and talking about how
he needs cash
as part
of some mysterious plan.
And he was recorded
by a world-renowned
investigative reporter,
better known as Borat.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Rudy records himself
saying incriminating things
all the time.
Before he talks to anyone,
he should pat himself down
to make sure he's not
wearing a wire.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Giuliani ]
Check him, to make sure
he's not wearing anything.
"He's clean, boss."
[ As Giuliani ]
Now, check me.
"Uh, not good, boss.
You're wearing two wires
and you have an open voice memo
recording on your phone."
[ As Giuliani ]
Oh, Rudy, you done it again!
[ Laughter and applause ]
After he pulled out, Rudy went
on Steve Bannon's podcast
to explain his decision
and did not do himself
any favors.
-Are you saying your concern is
they would doctor the tape
and hold it back?
-[ Laughs ]
-You want --
[ Laughter ]
-Come on!
This is not --
This is not your first ro--
This is not your first rodeo.
-You got a bunch of people
on that committee
that tried to frame the sitting
president of the United States,
and I'm going to trust them?
Do I look like a fool?
[ Laughter ]
-[ Measuredly ] Do you look like
a fool?
[ Laughter ]
Well...
♪♪
[ Laughter and applause ]
We've used that last photo
so often,
I've started keeping one in my
wallet now for emergencies.
[ Laughter ]
There he goes.
[ Laughter and applause ]
It's fun when I say, "You want
to see a picture of my son?
[ Laughter ]
Aah!"
Anyway, the important point is,
now that Rudy is refusing
to testify,
the committee is threatening
to hold him in contempt.
-Giuliani's decision
to stonewall the committee
now puts him on the very same
path as other Trump allies,
like Mark Meadows,
Dan Scavino, and Steve Bannon.
The panel today
dangling the prospect
of holding Giuliani in contempt,
saying this...
-Hey, committee, I don't know
how any of this works,
but can you stop waiting
until people don't show up
before you start considering
what their punishment will be?
Why can't you just say,
before they don't show up,
"Either be here
at the appointed time,
or you're going to jail
and bad news --
they don't have jumpsuits
in your size...
[ Laughter ]
...because that's not a size."
It's worth remembering
this guy was
the president's
personal attorney.
Look, I don't want to put words
in his mouth,
but I'm starting to think
the people who work for Trump
might be --
and perhaps this is harsh --
effing losers.
-The president is ranting
at the room.
He's using a lot of,
you know, foul language,
you know,
"You all are [effing] losers."
[ Laughter ]
-So that's
the former Secretary of Defense
Mark Esper.
You'd be forgiven
for not recognizing him,
since Trump cycled
through more defense secretaries
than actors
who've played Doctor Who.
[ Laughter ]
Sorry, uh, The Doctor.
I know what it is.
I did it on purpose
to see how many of you
would get your TARDIS
in a twist.
[ Laughter ]
In fact, I guarantee
at least one person
watching this segment online
paused the video
as soon as I said that
to write, in all-caps...
[ Laughter ]
And then, when they clicked
Play again
and saw that
I corrected myself,
they added a follow-up comment
that said...
[ Laughter ]
Esper was recounting a meeting
in the Oval Office
where Trump suggested
putting active duty troops
in the streets
to suppress lawful protests
against police brutality
in 2020.
And, in the course
of that meeting,
he apparently looked directly
at his own vice president
and called Mike Pence a loser.
-The president is ranting
at the room.
He's using a lot of,
you know, foul language,
you know, "You all are
[effing] losers," right?
And then he says it to the
vice president, Mike Pence.
He's using the same language
and he's looking at Pence.
-He called Mike Pence
an effin' loser?
-He didn't call him directly,
but he was looking at him
when he was saying it
and it really
caught my attention.
-Trump called his aides,
including his own
vice president, Mike Pence,
[bleep] losers.
I have to imagine
that's when Pence went
into chameleon mode again.
You know that thing he does
where he closes his eyes
[ Laughter ]
and tries to blend
into the background,
hoping to disappear?
It's the same he does
when he's walking in the zoo
and he sees two monkeys
getting it on.
[ As Pence ]
This isn't happening.
[ Laughter and applause ]
They're just wrestling.
[ Laughter ]
It looks like he's waiting
for Scotty
to beam him out of there.
[ As Pence ]
This is Commander Pence.
Away Team is ready.
Energize.
[ Transporter energizing ]
[ Laughter ]
So, why was Trump calling them
[bleep] losers?
Because they referenced
"Doctor Who" and "Star Trek"
in the same "Closer Look"?
Surprisingly, no.
[ Laughter ]
He called them losers
because he wanted them
to put active duty troops in the
street to attack protesters
and they refused,
according to Esper.
-And I thought that,
"We're in a different spot now.
He's going to finally
give a direct order
to deploy paratroopers
into the streets
of Washington, D.C.,"
and I'm thinking
with weapons and bayonets.
This would be horrible.
-What, specifically,
was he suggesting
that the U.S. military
should do to these protesters?
-He says,
"Can't you just shoot them?
Just shoot them in the legs
or something."
And he's suggesting that
that's what we should do,
that we should bring in the
troops and shoot the protesters.
-The commander-in-chief
was suggesting
that the U.S. military
shoot protesters?
-Yes, in the streets
-American protesters?
-of our nation's capital.
That's right.
Shocking.
-It is shocking.
So shocking,
you should've told us
about it at the time.
It's also, somehow,
not surprising to me
that Trump would specifically
request paratroopers,
although it also
wouldn't surprise me
if he didn't know
what that word meant.
I mean, maybe he knows
it's parachutes,
or maybe he thinks
it's the two guys from "CHiPs."
[ Laughter ]
[ As Trump ] Ponch and Jon --
a finer pair of troopers
you'll never see.
[ Laughter ]
We love Ponch and Jon, don't we?
The great Erik Estrada.
[ Laughter ]
I met him once at a charity
golf tournament
and I said to him,
I said to him, "Erik!
[ Laughter ]
I love your show,
but why are there never
any delicious chips?
[ Laughter ]
It seems like
false advertising."
And he said, "Are you joking?"
I said, "I wish I was, Erik.
I wish I was, but I'd love --
[ Laughter ]
I'd love to see chips,
if the show is called "CHiPs."
And he says,
"CHiPs is an acronym,"
and I just laugh because I don't
know what that word means.
[ Laughter ]
I don't know what it means,
so I just laugh.
I wandered off!
[ Laughter ]
Trump was an aspiring
authoritarian
who wanted to use the power
of the state
to violently suppress dissent
and keep himself in power.
We don't need any more evidence
to prove that
these two statements are true,
but we keep getting it, anyway,
and yet, his closest confidants
are refusing to comply
with the lawful investigation
into Trump's attempted coup.
If Rudy did show up
for the interview,
I imagine it would go
something like this.
-Do I look like a fool?
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over two million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS,
cancer, and other
serious illnesses
and they need your help,
now, more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the Donate button.
Stay safe. Get vaccinated.
We love you.